leute ganz kurz doch schöne grüße aus
dem film ich muss noch mal kurz das klar
schon damit dass jetzt nicht verwirrend
rüberkommen und zwar geht es in diesem
video um den am schlechtesten bewerteten
weiß dass es richtig ist ich weiß auch
nicht egal ihr wisst was ich meine um
den am schlechtesten bewertet also in
diesem video geht es um ein asiatisches
restaurant das am schlechtesten bewertet
ist aus ganz köln eigentlich ging es am
anfang die ganze zeit um in china
restaurant war irgendwie kann ich im
restaurant sondern einen teil des jungen
das ist ja ein unterschied deswegen nur
kurz zur aufklärung wundert euch nicht
wenn ich die ganze zeit am anfang schien
nach ersten tage alt aber war das ein
leute genau hier lag hat mein laptop mit
der kamera drauf und ich hatte eine fast
wunder geschmissen und habe mir dabei
meine musik knochen gestoßen also
nochmal hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut
ja ich muss mich ein bisschen beeilen
weil wir haben ja schon 18 uhr und ich
musste eigentlich schon wieder hier sein
weil ich dann wieder und dann stellen
möchte deswegen fangen wir direkt auch
mal an ihr habt wahrscheinlich haben
hier schon gelesen es geht heute um das
schlechteste china restaurant aus meiner
stadt also aus köln ich habe ja vor
einiger zeit schon mal den schlechtesten
bürgerladen gemacht was hatte ich noch
den schlechtesten friseur genau das auch
also halt so leben die im internet eine
total schlechte bewertung haben und ich
habe mir gedacht warum machst du das
format ich einfach weiter und deswegen
machen wir es heute
genau nicht viel spaß also wir machen es
natürlich weiter ich weiß war unnötig
leute ich habe mich natürlich im vorfeld
schon ein bisschen informiert und
einlagen rausgesucht und ich dachte
wirklich so 'oh mein gott was ist das
denn wie kommt das zustande weil ich sag
mal so ein sterne bewertungen haben
meistens nur läden die nur von einer
person bewertet wurden sobald anhalt
fünf personen bewertet haben ist das
dann mindestens zwei sterne weil
irgendwem gefällt's halt immer zur not
halt den besitzer
versteht ihr was ich meine und dann
nicht auf diesen laden gestoßen mich
zensiert das jetzt einfach mal weil ich
niemanden hier irgendwie was schlechtes
möchte oder so ist ja klar
gut wenn ihr euch jetzt hinsetzt und
euch die mühe macht findet man das denke
ich sowieso auf jeden fall geht es heute
um dieses ladenlokal ihr wir haben
wirklich sechs rezension wir haben sogar
noch rezension auf anderen webseiten
dich auch noch gefunden habe und alle
sind wirklich original ein stern also
das schlechteste ich glaube es gibt in
ganz köln kein restaurant egal was im
restaurant dass ein stern hat und von
sechs leuten gehört wurde wir lesen uns
einfach mal durch ganz knapp der kunde
der kunden umgegangen wird absolute
frechheit kundenumgang absolute
frechheit wenn ich könnte würde ich -
fünf sterne vergeben tut euch einen
gefallen und lass die finger von dem
laden selbst soll ein überteuertes und
derart schlechtes essen gehabt im grunde
noch nie einfach nur ekelhaft und
unverschämt solche preise dafür zu
verlangen oder den hier noch ich habe
gestern war es von hinten über
lieferando gestellt so was so schlimm
ist habe ich nie erlebt die choristen
fertig war aber okay die beschwerten
sich einfach nur also nachdem ich das
gelesen habe habe ich mich natürlich
schon gedacht okay ob es diesen lagen
noch gibt weiß ich nicht deshalb habe
ich angerufen ist allerdings mehr
angegangen das fand ich schon krass und
dann habe ich gestern abend wirklich
durch zufall ja den gleichen laden
gefunden unter anderem namen
wahrscheinlich haben die halt einfach
eine namensänderung gemacht um halt von
dieser schlechten bewertung wegzukommen
sind jetzt allerdings trotzdem nur weil
26 stellen was natürlich jetzt nicht so
schlecht ist allerdings wenn man schon
diese ganzen schlechten bewertungen hat
einen neuen laden eröffnet und immer
noch sehr schlechte bewertung kriegt
also wahrscheinlich mir wirklich frage
wie schlecht sind die leute hinter
diesem ressort von einem teil weit
entfernt zwei sterne
also es ist halt alles schlecht leute
und darum geht es ja in diesen videos
fahren jetzt einfach mal hin und
bestellen da was zu essen und ich bin
wirklich gespannt was mich da erwartet
hier vom schlimmsten aus ja ich will
nicht lange gelagert
bis gleich im auto ganz wichtig noch
falls ihr bock auf weitere parks haben
lassen wir gerne nach oben ich schreibe
es in die kommentare womit und jetzt
geht's los
solche irgendwie immer wenn ich in
diesem fall schütteln heute bin ich mal
wirklich überhaupt mich mit meiner
frisur zufrieden dann wisst ihr aber
eigentlich schon es geht wieder um essen
ich bin wie ich bin wirklich seit
gestern morgen viel unterwegs gewesen
aber es ging die ganze zeit immer nur
mein essens video
weil ich die ganze zeit essen des videos
gedreht haben also ein bisschen auch
sofort produzieren dann war ich
irgendwie so drin
und jetzt geht es weiter ich bin
gespannt leute dreiviertelstunde später
ich hab kein paar kritik von dass es so
krass in köln vor allem wenn andere
feierabend haben du findest keinen
parkplatz
jetzt stehe ich hier voll schlecht und
ich habe auch richtig angst dass ich
hier so harmlose antwort gibt die dann
halt immer gucken wer falsch parkt und
direkt ein abschleppdienst rufen
deswegen bei uns jetzt richtig und ich
kann doch leider nicht da ist würde ich
natürlich überwachen aber ich habe angst
dass sonst mein auto abgeschleppt wird
mit auto kommt man hier nur sehr
schlecht hin deswegen tut mir leid ich
bin jetzt auch sprachen joggen damit ich
das noch packe hast du was ich noch
sagen wollte
ich bin jetzt nicht so optimistisch
essen einer ich hoffe ich finde mein
auto wieder
ich bin jetzt nicht so optimal sich
essen wenn dann nehme ich aber immer das
gleiche und das nehmen wir dann
natürlich auch falls sie das haben ich
habe den laden aber grad schon gesehen
weil ich daran lang gefahren bin war
natürlich kein kundenparkplatz nur so
aber alles okay in köln wo und jetzt
muss ich mal kurz gucken wo ich hier
gelandet
ich finde mein auto niemals wieder leute
das ist der laden sieht irgendwie gut
aus also im internet seite anders aus
also ganz anders
[Musik]
so leute es muss mir noch schnell geld
holen weil man da natürlich nur bezahlen
kann aber ich meine es okay
[Musik]
b
leute zurück im auto ich dachte erst ich
hab' ich verrat 16 euro also da bin ich
jetzt wirklich mal gespannt wie fair
nach hause testen das und so leute also
wieder zurück jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
gesehen der laden war als ich wirklich
der einzige sohn von 932 sollte ja
eigentlich so rasch aus also dieser
einblick in die küche sei es auch noch
wirklich hübsch aus aber wir probieren
das gleich mal und ich bin wirklich
gespannt was die mir für 16 euro also
bekomme ich mein name ist doch klar
gekocht haben ich habe einen
hauptgericht genommen und so eine kleine
beilagen ja so ist das so
also leute ich hab ja gerade eben schon
gesagt ich bin jetzt wirklich mal extrem
gespannt wie viel das ist ob das
schmeckt und ja ich komme immer noch
nicht auf diese 16 euro klar das ding
ist nämlich ich habe modeln mit hähnchen
bestellt nudeln kosten ja nix hähnchen
kostet auch nicht viel
deswegen wie man da auf 16 euro kommt
weiß ich nicht haben wir auf jeden fall
schon mal den tipp für ein kleines
dankeschön danken für 16 euro ist halt
auch mal drin oder fangen wir mal mit
dem ersten gericht ob er gut was heißt
gericht also ich habe mir
frühlingsrollen bestellt einfach weil
ich die sehr gern esse und mal schauen
wie die schmecken
[Musik]
das habe ich dir mal den djp getunkt mal
gespannt
[Musik]
gut kann man sicherlich auch nicht so
viel falsch machen
trotzdem muss ich sagen ich habe selten
so gut befriedigen werden
auch der deb ist wirklich sehr sehr gut
also ich habe zwei gegessen wirklich
echt lecker also bis jetzt gibt es
überhaupt nichts zu meckern es kommen
wir allerdings mal zu hauptkampf denke
mal dieses gericht kostet 12 euro dann
und die frühlingsrollen 4
das würde mich am meisten sinn machen
ich habe jetzt keinen kassenzettel dabei
ich habe einfach die gerichte gesagt
deswegen keine ahnung
dazu kann ich allerdings auch sagen dazu
kommt noch ich komme hier nicht aus köln
vielleicht ist das auch normal für eine
großstadt asiaten großstadt asiate
vielleicht gibt es das wort gar nicht
nein
aber bei uns zuhause kosten diese beiden
sachen zusammen vielleicht die hälfte
gabel ist sogar mit dabei also noch mal
für euch nicht eigentlich ganz gut so
für mich
[Musik]
hier musste ich jetzt sagen das steckt
man nicht so gut schmeckt wirklich sehr
trocken also da habe ich schon deutlich
besseres gegessen die nudeln sind
eigentlich ganz lecker nur dieses gemüse
keine ahnung das schmeckt mir gar nicht
aber es jetzt nicht so als könnte man
das ich erst mal das schmeckt ok ich
muss sagen das wird noch mal den preis
denkt also der preis ist wirklich eine
frechheit finde ich ja kein wunder dass
da keiner kommt wenn ein gericht da bei
euch so teuer als ich weiß nicht
vielleicht sich das auch ein bisschen zu
eng
ich meine wenn man in einem restaurant
geht bezahlt man ja im durchschnitt
schon so gut 12 euro für ein mittagessen
das hier kostet in dem fall zwölf euro
für solche speisen einfach nicht gewohnt
ihr könnt mir gerne eure meinung dass
wir in die kommentare schreiben aber ich
muss sagen die frühlingsrollen ich werde
echt gut
das hier ist jetzt nicht so ganz mein
fall die innenausstattung von dem dinge
weiß auch nicht so super wobei ist auch
nicht schlecht war vielleicht ein
bisschen unhygienisch aus ich weiß nicht
mal 100 sich nun immer warum der laden
so schlecht bewertet ist hatte ich ja
bei meinem ersten test auch schon so
ähnlich
aber gut ich habe es getestet schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare was eben
noch testen soll
wenn ihr blick auf weitere parks habt
und ich genieße jetzt noch mal ein essen
und und gebt noch nach oben wenn ihr
sagt frühlingsrollen sind auf jeden fall
becker